all right guys bang-bang Jeremy's here
super excited about this thank you so
much for coming we got a lot to talk
about today because you come from the
non crypto world into the crypto world
let's start with background first
you started out doing everyone's
favorite activity tell us what we got
started all right well first thanks for
having me
I'm really excited to be here background
wise I started as an auditor after
getting a degree in accounting and
discovered in about six months that I
hated it but it took you till after the
degree to figure you know as yeah as bad
as that sounds I guess I was naive I was
I was pretty good at it in school and
didn't really dawn on me that I wouldn't
enjoy it after I got at school because
the school life and the actual career
life were pretty different when you talk
being an auditor you like flying to the
location you're locked in the room that
they've turned the AC up really high to
get you out of there quickly yeah more
or less I mean it was all in the
dallas-fort Worth Metroplex area so not
really on the air in airports for that
but it was insurance companies and very
much in the darkest corner of wherever
they could put you very much
stereotypical hope yeah all right so you
did that and then figured out maybe you
wanted to do something else was you next
yeah you know I wanted to get on the
right side of the income statement I was
keenly aware that no matter what I would
do with my career I was always gonna be
an expense and and I wanted to get on
the revenue producing side I actually
took a position to open an office in
Austin for a small third-party
administrator which runs corporate
health plans so larger companies would
partially sell fun and kind of create
their own health insurance products it
was a
really interesting b2b application of
the insurance world and launched an
office for them in Austin and had a lot
of fun doing it and and did well alright
and so how do you go from doing that to
managing the wealth of what I think
we've already dubbed as poor rich people
yeah before we start recording yeah
hopefully I hopefully my clients aren't
listening to this and won't hear me
lovingly refer to them as poor rich
people but um you know I I kind of
reached a point in my insurance world
where I had saturated the market we had
really conquered it and there wasn't
much for me to do and that's a really
bad place for me I can't be bored and so
I just started looking around and
thought well you know laterally
transition out of the insurance world in
the money game and I'm I started as a
rookie broker second career-wise and at
AG Edwards in Austin in the year 2000
just in time for the dot-com you ran
right into the teeth I'm perfect timing
what was it like so dot-com crash
happens it seems like the you know the
world's on fire what's going on inside
and you know you're second-guessing
yourself number one from walking away
from really good money to start over but
you know from a money perspective it
actually wasn't that bad because it's
it's hard enough to convince somebody to
let you manage your money when the world
is good you'd think it would be harder
when times were bad but not so much
people get insecure about what they're
doing and they're actually more willing
to listen so ironically even though it
sounds like that would be a hard time it
was perhaps maybe an easier time it's
interesting it's like the human
psychology of what do I need you for you
know Parker just won a 30% right you
know you're gonna beat that yeah versus
hey the market is went down 30%
now I'm Jim yeah for sure
and so after after you go through the
the first kind of teeth of a bear market
you ended up actually going through a
second one yeah so you know halfway in
the middle there we left the firm
started our own I had a partner and and
so we you know we were kind of
entrepreneurial already I wanted to
launch out on her own and then we went
through the Great Recession and that one
hurt more obviously because by that time
I was you know somewhat successful had
you know I I could swing hard in the
dot-com bubble and nobody didn't have
any money that I was actually
responsible for so I didn't have to
apologize but so that was harder and I
actually came out of that fairly
disillusioned you know it was kind of a
crossroads where I thought I'm either
gonna leave this business or find
another way to do it and and why a
different way to do it was like the kind
of warning signs you know I had begun to
dabble in alternative investments even
the largest brokerage houses on Wall
Street have you know silos of
alternative investments and it was for
whatever reason I was just naturally
drawn to that but I knew that it was you
know dull boring spoons it wasn't you
know you cannot provide big legions of
advisors in the merrill lynch's of the
world of UBS as a world with sharp
instruments where they can hurt
themselves in other words about it's
about capacity if you can't take if you
can't adjust a hundred million dollars
of new capital a month into your
strategy you can't be on a big platform
so that that kind of takes away the
inherent positive idiosyncratic risk
profiles of what that entire asset class
was designed for yeah and so how do you
go from there's a different way to do
this that might be interesting to
actually know how to do it yeah it's a
pretty big learning curve really seen a
huge learning curve and basically I sort
of decided that people with real money
100 million dollar-plus money probably
weren't managing money the way that I
was and I didn't know how I didn't know
how to figure that out but I set about
trying to network into the family office
world and you got to understand the
family office world doesn't hire brokers
or advisers they put people on payroll
in their office and so those two worlds
are pretty exclusive though they don't
usually find a way to connect and you
know but I had a connection there was a
family office in Chicago worth a hundred
million and another one worth 150 and
they were patriarchs of families whose
children were now adults and they were
seeking to empower the second generation
of wealth to kind of crystallize a
business around taking the
quarter billion dollars in inviting
other really wealthy families and join
them in the classic multi-family office
sense of the word but they've never done
it before I on the other hand had
launched my own advisory firm twice and
knew how to interface with the regulator
so I kind of talked my way into a job as
their chief compliance and chief
operating officer in exchange for a seat
at their investment table which which
was a just a total blast for four years
you know every time they got an airplane
I went with them and learned all about
you know hedge fund investing private
equity direct deals real estate direct
deals venture capital it was it was it
became the education that I needed on
which to form the the center of my
current practice well there's two pieces
here right so the first is that there's
a big difference in the mentality and
kind of the practice of investing
depending on the capital pool so if
you're kind of an everyday American I'm
fifty percent of Americans don't have
any money to invest at all right they're
living paycheck to paycheck can't come
up with 400 500 bucks emergency payment
they're obviously in a very different
situation than everyone else who the
other 50% that have capital to invest
but inside of that I have capital to
invest bucket you get the people who
really probably have enough capital to
put into the SMP and kind of more
passively invest yeah then you get you
know what I lovingly described as like
the poor rich people which is you know
kind of 20 million dollars or less which
sounds like a lot of money to everybody
right but when you start to look at how
do you invest in all these multiple
asset classes well many of these asset
classes you can't actually get exposure
to them without putting you know one to
five million dollars yeah and so if you
know you got it for five million dollars
in real estate you got the five million
dollars in stocks could put five million
dollars in bonds you got the five
million dollars and fix things you know
you got online you've run out of 20
million dollars pretty quickly yeah so
you actually don't have the capital pool
to invest like a big institution would
but I think what you're talking about is
these family offices that usually it's
some sort of generational wealth right
they've created you go through a
business they own or inheritance or
whatever they can invest like an
institution right there especially a
small institution and
the ability to put millions of dollars
into each strategy and build comfort
diversify portfolio is available to them
and so it's that mind [ __ ] mindset shift
or change that sounds like you really
want to go see like how do I learn that
yeah there's a lot into unpacking what
you just said it's really a passion
point for me the the laws that regulate
the quote unquote private placement
world haven't been changed in decades I
mean 1940 the advisors Act was really
the last major piece of legislation that
governs how to qualify for participating
in proper placement works private
placement deals so it's kind of
interesting that hundred million dollar
families very often create product that
is really just meant for an accredited
investor which you you and I both know
means you got a million dollars
basically with a couple other caveats
but but they've got a hundred million
dollars right well they only need a
hundred you only get a hundred slots in
an accredited product well they don't
need a hundred spots so ironically
they're creating product with a hunter
slots for ten or fifteen of their
friends and there's all this room on the
backside so if you figure out how to
plug into that deal flow Network and you
respect them and you ask good questions
and you get on airplanes and you go
visit them and you're you're interested
in their projects you don't actually
always have to put one two five million
dollars in these deals as an advisor I
represent twentyish families and and my
capital commitment to that deal is
meaningful to them even though at a
ticket level it's very often you know
hundred thousand or 250 s so it's what I
discovered in that regulatory framework
that allows me to go port to that
hundred million dollar thinking down to
this five to twenty five million dollar
world in a very compelling way that that
doesn't seem like it should work yeah
and I think the other piece of this is
the not only how they think about it but
also you
in an effort to learn did probably
support thing people can do is just you
wouldn't surround yourself people doing
what you wanted to do yeah right and I
get young kids who especially like right
out of college who write to me all the
time and said hey I want to do X what
you know what's your advice no I say
look first of all you shouldn't be
asking me for advice because I don't
know your situation right some some
random guy and your some random guys how
do I give you advice I don't really know
but one piece of advice that ends up
working regardless of who you are what
you want to go do etc is just go find
people who've already done it yeah I
I'll teach you I tell my kids and I and
I try to practice as myself you know it
doesn't help you to be the smartest guy
in the room in fact rather you really
need to find a way to be the dumbest guy
in the smartest room because there's
upside there no upside to being the
smartest guy in the room for sure sorry
so you you go for four years or so and
you're kind of getting this crash course
any like really really special deals
that that stick out your mind is like it
was you know kind of just a crash course
in the type of investing or something
you knew nothing about that you got to
speak really quickly oh I don't know
that I could pick one out particularly
we did we did a number of hedge fund
deals early and and maybe I can kind of
bifurcate them into two different worlds
one of them was coming to grips with 100
million dollar wealth being okay with a
5% return in a market neutral strategy
that was supposed to get ten but somehow
all we've got five my clients didn't
like that so there was a big I had to
make a shift to understand 25 million
dollars absolutely does not think like
hundred million dollars but but I
specifically around the return profile
oh for sure yeah I mean if you make five
percent on a hundred million dollars
life is gonna be okay yeah people don't
actually even though it's true in some
sense of where people don't actually
feel that way with twenty five as much
not anywhere near as much but at a deal
level to be more specific to your your
question we did put some money in a you
know structured product deal right
around the big short deal with the
mortgage
deal and that was fun to watch it was it
was really fun to find a thesis that was
contrarian to you know very complicated
product to get your head wrapped around
it find enough confidence to put an
allocation and then then just watch it
take off yeah those are always fun yeah
and we taught their broth around that
return profile right is there's a very
offensive and defensive mindset
difference between 25 million in last
and oh you know hundred million and more
and this sounds absolutely insane to
anyone who is a normal American right
the average American is like what are
you talking about yeah but you know and
I've gotten this crash course over the
last two years or so going and talking
to a lot of these family offices etc
there's a very big difference that 25
million dollar family wants to be the
hundred million dollar family right it's
the keeping up with the Joneses and in a
you know on steroids basically yeah 100
million dollar plus family actually
understands I got 40 million dollars
right like I want to keep the wealth I
have and so there's a offensive verse
defensive mindset and you would think
that for the everyday American hey if I
got twenty five million dollars I'm
protecting the hell out of that right
but it's just they slowly go from they
have nothing to they have a million
bucks to five million bucks at 10:25 and
they still looking up saying how do I
get to 100 how do I get to you know more
yes I have I have a theory or two about
that I you know you can you can have a
good career and cobble together a
million two million three million bucks
but if you get multiple tens of millions
you did something special and normally
people that do something special have a
really strong type a conquer the world
mentality they're taking entrepreneurial
risk they're doing something risky and
and it's it is about the wealth
generation you know people do end up at
100 but sometimes that guy he's the guy
who went from 2 million to 25 and now
he's at a hundred but at some point
along the way he retires and and it
actually becomes more about the
psychology of generational shifts where
the second generation doesn't have that
they in fact they're they don't they
know they don't have it
and so it's more of protect and preserve
so there's a couple of died and not
there's no there's no stereotypical
thing every family is different but
these are generational shifts and sort
of wealth accumulation shifts that kind
of happened in my experience yeah the
one of the most powerful things somebody
said to me early in life was they said a
million dollars a lot of money right and
I was like of course right I was you
know 18 year old kid I was like Jesus
Christ million dollars like I'd do
anything for that right and and they
said if you're a teacher in most places
right and let's say you were somebody to
40 50 thousand dollars a year right
which probably an average salary if you
work for 20 years made a million dollars
right now there's taxes you got expenses
or also have stuff but it is achievable
if there's a long enough timeframe right
and so what he basically was explaining
to me was like look a million dollars is
a lot of money in short bursts right if
you make a million dollars in a year if
you if you sell something make a million
dollars whatever but over a long enough
period of time even if the salary level
is low you can accumulate top-line
dollars yeah but there's taxes and
what's your expense ratio right if you
make fifty thousand but you spend sixty
well you're not gonna keep anything
right now
but if you make fifteen you spend ten
actually you know twenty twenty-five
years later you have million dollars I
can remember being a sophomore in
college thinking you know when I'm out
of this place in a few years if I could
just make sixty five thousand dollars a
year life is gonna be great yeah life's
changed it's and it's for multiple
reasons right there there's the
inflation right so everything you
continue to get more expensive but also
there is this element of you don't
expect the expenses that you have yeah
you know as you get older right you get
a family you get how all things right so
it's really interesting all right so
let's talk about kind of after you got
that crash course right you spent four
years going and seeing all these things
what did you change
in terms of how you worked with your
clients on the wealth management side so
they don't have a hundred million
dollars but they're kind of in that five
to twenty five million dollar range etc
what was the general you know change
that you saw or how did you talk to them
differently you know it really was there
are a small hint maybe I'd have to think
about three four five clients that are
holdovers that crossed that bridge so it
was actually 100 to 25 well no no no
that I'm saying people that were my
clients got it in the old world that
migrated with me so it was actually more
of a turning over of my business it was
a it was a shift it was a shift and and
who you want to work who I wanted to
work with interesting who would work
with me okay we want explain that one
you know you just start you know you
just people tap out right i you know i
think the the bond market today you know
with a to handle pretty pretty
unattractive place to try to collect a
yield do i like tax liens where you know
there's a really sharp tax lien
strategies you can clip and a really
conservative way six seven eight nine
percent a year with with a really secure
piece of real estate backing you up
right why wouldn't i do that like you
have to take liquidity risk you don't
have it's obviously not as liquid but if
you're if you're wealthy enough to have
that much capital you don't need the
liquidity right so it's it's a shift
from normal traditional you know Modern
Portfolio Theory 6040 stock bond
allocation thinking to now we're gonna
think different and we're going to
really evaluate risk differently we're
going to stop trying to pay attention to
correlation matrices across large
timeframes and start paying attention to
what what happens to correlation
matrices when everything blows up
because that's really only time it
matters nobody cares about correlation
when everything's good it's just when it
goes down all right this is important
because I don't think a lot of people
think about that nuanced explained in
more
why that is like why should people care
about the correlation on the downsize
from the bad cases and some not so much
on the on the upside
well because everything's the the whole
point of diversification is to protect
your capital in negative events right
there is no other reason to if there
were never any negative events you
wouldn't need to diversify you just beam
along everything and it would always go
up so the question then becomes well if
if I think that you know investment a an
investment B have a not very strong
correlation and I project that across
all timeframes whether the markets going
up whether it's sideways or whether it's
going down I may miss the fact that in
fact it might be positively correlated
in a rising market but strongly
negatively correlated in a falling
market or vice versa and invariably what
we see is in a capitalist world system
in a capitalist system that we have here
in this country you have everything
everything connect everything connects
everything else the the high-yield bond
market connects to the equity market the
the you know the globalization means the
international markets connect to the US
markets the growth and value investors
both get their head handed to them when
profits go down and people start paying
less for profit dollar on the S&P and
and so that's when it matters it only
matters and the more crazy things we do
in monetary policy to try to manipulate
that game the harder things adjust when
we can no longer can yeah and I mean
it's pretty clear that's what's going on
right is every time we start to get
towards these negative moments central
banks do two things right they cut the
interest rates and they start printing
money and it seems like now we're we've
entered a world where they could have
interest rates is pretty well understood
there's lots of speculation on what
they're going to do you know each
decision point but on the printing of
money it's no longer are they gonna do
all right right it's pretty much look
we're addicted to this and we're gonna
have to keep some rate
of inflating the monetary supply in
order to you know keep kind of this
train going because if they stop it's
gonna get ugly pretty quickly
yeah I'm not I'm not afraid or averse to
taking directional market risk but what
I'm saying is to have safety in your
portfolio there is no real safe assets
in my opinion in most traditional
markets you have to go find you know tax
lien investment or a life settlements
investment or private debt real deals we
love what we call the pawnshop business
model where you go lend somebody money I
don't care whether you pay me back or
not your collateral worth I'll take your
collateral and I'll make my money on
your collateral or you'll pay me back
and there's all kinds of investment
opportunities like that if you do your
research you can you can clip near
double-digit yields in a portfolio
explain you can give me like an example
of one of those cuz I think the private
credit space is one that we've spent the
least amount of time talking about sure
but I've got a very good friend who runs
a shop and that's been one of their main
focuses recently is private credit and
I'm personally fascinated by if you find
the right opportunities it can be quite
lucrative sure it's you know so let's
say let's say you've got a I'm just let
me I'm just trying to think of a deal
give me a second here so see you guys
then I'm asking for deals right now deal
flow you know you got a you got a
multifamily project in a good market you
know call it I mean I'm making this up
but its representative but like in a
market like Austin Austin Texas we love
we love Austin Austin's got really great
yeah it's huge and so you got a deal in
Austin it's it's poorly managed it's
half full the the the owner of the
property it's got deferred maintenance
he's been living off of the rents that
he should have been pouring back into
the property it's starting to circle the
drain you can tell it's you know he's
gonna have to hand the keys back to the
bank right some other developer comes
along and he finds it's a value-add play
it's a classic real estate value i play
he buys the dirt really cheap out of
foreclosure bankruptcy foreclosure and
he capitalizes deal appropriately you
know fixes the deferred maintenance gets
it pretty again and re tenants it right
as you go from half fold a full and so
there's two ways to win on that there's
the entrepreneurial equity side where
you're not going to cover off the ball
if you actually execute but you can also
win on that deal by being the debt guy
like I'm gonna give you fifty cents in
the dollar I mean you you know if you
manure depending on the cap rates you
buy that there's a way to conservatively
lend money on that deal so that if and
as the senior lender if he screws up you
take the keys so so as long as you lend
it for a dollar that is at or below fire
sale prices so that you know that in 24
hours you can get rid of the property
and get your money back that's a really
strong compelling asymmetric risk return
profile I get my capital back in the
worst case event I get my capital back
plus typically ten twelve percent
Interest if I'm right yeah the part to
me that as I spent more time with folks
in the family office world that I don't
think I really understood much every
game you play in life right what you
wanna do is want to stack the deck in
your favor right so what that means is
I'm going to try to figure out pieces of
information before other people I'm
gonna try to find something other people
can't find ready to I have a strategy no
one else understands all these different
things that's true in sports that's true
in you know board games whatever that's
what family offices you know especially
the wealthy ones are doing in private
investing yeah I'll tell you a deal
just cuz I'm thinking about it as you're
saying it but this is an actual real
live deal that I'm doing in Austin can I
get in
and it's no please nobody call on this
because it's actually fully capitalized
I don't have there's no more room but
but basically you see me using the
podcast for deals out there no real
strategy has been revealed no it's it's
it's an RV park so in Austin there's
such a dearth of workforce housing
there's just not enough supply cannot
keep up with the demand people are
living full-time in RV parks I didn't
believe it at first but I
when I heard that I literally booked a
flight went to Austin and walked the
parks to go figure and it's unbelievable
to me he's like what like tech workers
these are more like blue colleges it's
it's comfortable it's both because
there's also this kind of virus they
fire financially independent retire
early minute you know minimalistic
millennial ethic you know the tiny home
movement that's all big in Austin as
well so you could have an $80,000 tiny
home sitting on a pad next to a five
thousand dollar used you know pop-up
trailer yeah and that's neat it's really
fascinating
you know we basically bought thirty
acres of dirt on the edge of Austin and
we're developing a new RV park and it's
really hard to get the permitting
entitlement done correctly but basically
if you do you can create excuse me a
really interesting gated community with
curb streets and and and not a blight on
the community and provide on thirty
acres three hundred housing units for
this workforce housing and the economics
are incredible it's it's six to seven
hundred month for the dirt rental per
pad yeah
what's crazy about this so I know
somebody who did this with mobile homes
no video buy the dirt they bought the
actual mobile homes themselves and
rented him out one of the things that I
had never thought of until I actually
went and saw what they were doing is how
much more dense the acreage can be when
you're renting it out right it's kind of
with their we work model was yeah we
work went in and took a big space and
then cut it up right and then rent it
out in little slices and made uh well if
they were supposed to make a sum upside
her or you know net something thereon
I'm doing that same model here you could
buy thirty acres right when you cut that
up if each piece is on a dot you know
per dollar basis higher when you rent it
out cut up you're gonna make money yeah
we're gonna stabilize this project you
know we're expecting to break ground
late summer but it's about sixty nine
months in construction time to get it on
to get to get the infrastructure laid
but we expect to stabilize it at you
know mid-teens cap rate and compress
into a sale at eight which which which
is fancy way of saying
we think we can turn ten million dollars
into 20 in a three year period of time
and the upside is compelling the
downside is pretty minimal
I mean you know the dirt is on the edge
of Austin it's on a killer corner in a
really busy place and so if I don't get
the right to build the park I can sell
the land today for more than I bought it
you know so we love those asymmetries
yeah and part of this too is you're
talking about doubling your money right
what will get script owners like me you
have to most people encrypt a double
your money doesn't sound right right but
you're talking about combining upside
with risk profile they buy that risk
profile the part that you also hinted at
I think a lot of people don't understand
is when you have wealth like many of
these families do times on their side so
if they buy that piece of property and
all of a sudden you know markets crash
prices go down they don't get the
approvals to build etc the worst case
scenario is that they left holding it we
become a land bank on a really good
piece of dirt and one of the best
markets in the country in five to ten
years from now it'll be worth 2 to 3 x
anyways yeah right and so it really
comes down to what those liquidity needs
are and kind of what the appetite is to
the investor and I think that that's one
of the things that the public markets
probably don't provide or I just given
this daily price yeah lots of fun
volatility
they got television shows talking about
it right they've got newspaper headlines
like you know all this stuff's going on
and it's very easy for people to get in
their own way and make emotional
decisions but in these private markets
it's a little bit harder to do just
given the nature of the asset yeah I
think real risk management and this is
this is just me talking but it really
comes down to what's your upside
downside and what's the probability of
those outcomes right if if I have a
upside of 2x and a downside of breakeven
you take that bet all the time right if
I have an upside of 2x and a downside of
lose everything
I better be right more than half the
time or I'm not making money right so
that's why even something as crazy
aggressive as crypto is compelling
because there's a small right tail
exposure two to five percent you can go
to zero I'm okay with that for the trade
of it going 20 to 100 X I mean I'm
making that number up but it's if you
have enough upside and you can throw
that bet enough times you're gonna
compound capital yeah the numbers over
the last five years and these numbers
are a couple of months old so just
generally this was correct over five
years 6040 global portfolio gave you
seven point two percent annualized
return if you had taken half a percent
from stocks half a percent from bonds
put one percent in the Bitcoin you would
from 7.2 to nine point two so 200 basis
point upside if it had gone to zero you
would have lost 20 basis points in two
to seven so you have a ten to one upside
down he's exactly talking about and by
the way in the worst case scenario where
you lose it all that means you lost one
percent of your assets right right which
nobody wants to lose money but you've
contained the risk and so I think that
that's part of this as well is what
scares me personally is I see you know K
you know folks on on Twitter who are
like look I'm a hundred percent great
right and what I always say to somebody
when they ask you know is that a good
allocation I said it's impossible to
answer that question right because guess
what for a 16 year old kid who's got a
hundred bucks earn 3% or 2% on bonds is
probably not gonna get it done right and
so it's such a small amount when he
compared the earning power yes that's a
very different he's not spending it on
on on stocks and bonds maybe he's
spending it on his girlfriend or on
video games or of course right and so
it's you know I use it as an egregious
example yeah but when you start to look
at the 25 year old who's got you know a
decent job at their first job out of
school they don't have any wealth saved
up but they also have a lot of expenses
has a very different risk return profile
that they're targeting then you know the
50 year old who's got three kids that
are in college right now you know right
high expense ratio etc and so I think
that that's the mentality in the
education around these investors to me
has been the most shocking thing coming
from more of the tech industry into
fields it just blows me away how
not uneducated just unexposed to what
the wealthiest people in the world yeah
it's it's fascinating it's it's it's
really more about psychology than then
then then the algebra and and
understanding that psychology and and
getting people comfortable with taking
the right amount of risk and then that
whole conversation goes away from sides
more towards the art that more wealthy
they get because at a certain point they
can take more risk because they have
enough wealth in it they can risk more
because it doesn't matter to their life
or or not so it's just a really
fascinating nuanced conversation that is
part of why I get paid yeah well I'll
give you a give you one more that I
didn't understand this but there's a
young kid that I know who who basically
I talked to periodically and he said
something to me the effect of I spent
too much money okay and I said well you
know if you want to tell me tell me the
numbers and so he told it to me and I
said look you try to save $200 extra a
month right which to you sounds like it
would be that you know change your
lifestyle and essentially I said what if
I said do you gotta make $500 extra a
month so rather than trying to cap your
spending is it actually easier just to
go make $500 more a month
Yeah right and he basically kind of you
know faltered and I don't know you know
how am I gonna do that whatever that's
it don't look it's not it's an equation
right that there's inputs and output so
in this equation and if you spend more
money then you either gotta stop doing
that or you gotta make more money and
the making more money may actually be
easier for you so you don't have to
change your lifestyle and guess what if
you save $200 you make 500 more now she
end up with more money by making the 500
right right and so it's kind of trying
to expand the the mindset from not
always just being how do I contract how
do I spend less spend last night it's
well sometimes growth can actually get
you to where you want to go faster than
let me stop spending let me do for sure
totally
which I think a lot of you know of
investing that's how these wealthy
families think about it right how do I
grow
I have and in many cases if they're good
at it it's better than if they had a job
for sure yeah they can make they they
often do make significantly more in
their portfolios than they do in their
wages for sure how scripto fit into all
this
so you've got these these wealthy
families who are doing all kinds of
alternative investing exception and then
are you going to them saying check out
crypto or they come in to you saying
what the hell is this it's both for
crypto it was actually not a client
coming to me but I mean that's another
passion point of mine as I sit down with
my clients quarterly and I'm like you
know here's the numbers blah blah blah
what are you invested in right now that
isn't in my portfolio that you're super
excited about and every client gets that
question every quarter so there's a lot
of inbound deal flow that that I get to
be curious about what's the weirdest one
and peanuts shelling for peanut shelling
operation in South Carolina like he nuts
yeah so guys the peanuts out of the
farmers got the peanut crops and he's
tired of getting jacked around by the
shelling coop and he thinks
screw it I'm gonna go start my own
shelling deal and and I'm you know I get
that literally I got this call from a
client who got pitched this deal and I
had to start to try to figure out how to
get my heart a hand head wrapped around
that thang good deal it was a horrible
deal it was a great is a great idea is a
great idea but it's a bad structure
which happens all the time great ideas
get killed by bad structures all the
time when you say bad structure makes my
no more you know it's it's it's the
whole pre-money post-money valuation you
know how much the company is being sold
what is it a is it an equity instrument
is a dead instrumental you know what
what's the risk that I'm bearing for the
capital that I'm laying out and and such
parsing through the deal Docs and
figuring out where you are in the
capital stack and how much risk versus
how much of the upside that that's what
I'm talking about structures structures
can you can kill a good idea with a bad
structure yeah well it goes back to you
know
you name the price I'd name the terms
right negotiating with some right co-op
a billion-dollar company I'll pay a
dollar a day you know for the rest of
your life yeah look so but for crypto it
came actually from a friend of mine we
were sitting on his deck just you know
winners slowly waning away of a warmer
early spring day in 2017 he's like man
you got to take a look at this and and I
you know he's he's a kind of a trend guy
trades is Chicago Board of Trade so he
thinks about the world as a traitor and
I am at that time in 10 17 if I remember
had gone from like $10 at the start of
the year by jumped like 30s like a 3x
right around March time for yes he's
like I don't know I just put money in
and it keeps going up I'm and I'm like
well what is it he goes I don't know and
I can't I just that just doesn't hit my
gray I got to go figure out what it is
so I thought well figure that I'll spend
an hour tonight it took me forever just
to figure out I mean there was not
really any content online that was
readily available to even understand and
explain it so this is important point
right which is just somebody who knew
nothing about crypto you don't know
where to look right right you don't know
about the reddit subreddits you don't
know who to follow on Twitter yet right
that there's no idea that coin desk or
coin Telegraph right these kind of more
niche sites exist what you do is you
google right that's exactly what I did
and you find you know all kinds of stuff
Bloomberg article right and I just
picked a random one but you're talking
about something in 2014
yes exactly I got that article when
you're talking about yeah all right so
you go look at it I look at it and the
further in I guess I mean it's a rabbit
hole man I got I got in and it was you
know there's no getting out it just
fascinated me to know and I mean the it
is a tech I've remembered distinctly
okay true confessions college my senior
year I was in a class we had a group
project okay will the internet survive
and thrive
and really yeah and so this is where
this 19 this is 1993 or 94 okay so just
want to start maybe like ya know just
right right and so and we did our
research and we came back at the end of
said now there's no way there's security
risk yeah there's security risks like
who wants to go who wants to buy shoes
online I gotta go try them on like I'm
going to the mall like what like no
obviously stupid hindsight and after a
few years and I look back on that I'm
like wow that was really dumb like I
missed that one
and I'm like well that'll never happen
again in my lifetime and I distinctly
remember that moment coming back in my
mind when I started to understand what
crypto is cuz it's exactly that moment
again yeah what was the part that pulled
you in like what was so fascinating
about it when you start looking at just
intermediating third-party
intermediaries from the financial system
globally yeah just a small task yeah
we'll be done by lunch yeah yeah got it
and so what did you do initially once
you got interested well initially I
thought well this is this is great I'm
gonna go out launch a hedge fund I'll
pick coins well then I started doing a
little more work and I realized I don't
know how to program open source code I
can barely spell blockchain like I don't
know cryptography I couldn't tell you
good cryptography from bad cryptography
I don't I don't have these are really
deep Sciences with really smart people
that I'm not so I you know I didn't want
to be a poser and there actually there
are a fair number of poser hedge funds
out there that have none of those
credentials that are still somehow smart
in the space let's let seventeen if you
just picked anything you seemed right at
least right so the next best thing to me
was to resurrect the dying animal of fun
of funds in outside crypto fun of funds
is a dying animal there's no need for it
it served its purpose for a time but not
anymore
you want to talk about why they're dying
well sure fees access you know there's a
there's a natural penetration of of
capital in the arbitrage space that
diffuses returns I mean the competition
it's a more crowded fishbowl there's a
number of reasons
Marquess Co what my partner's they have
big fun fun to business yeah and he
basically says anything cuz that's dying
business and I said you know why and he
respond he goes the Internet
what do you mean the Internet and he
goes well it used to be that people
would come to a fund of funds and they
would say hey I have some money I'd like
to get into you know good hedge funds
for example and that fund of funds had
relationships access yeah right do the
returns and could pick it cetera he goes
now it's iGoogle top performing hedge
funds I see that you know Tiger global
is really high performer I go to their
website I click the contact us page and
I get a phone number and I call up and
say hey I have money would you take it
right yeah and they sometimes they say
yes sometimes they say no right that's
true but but in from a mechanism
standpoint I now know who to give it to
and now I just got to make sure that
they're willing to take it yeah but with
crypto there is relationship equity
there is access there is a repeat of
what and it won't the other it will run
its course and be useless and obsolete
sometime in the future as well but I
felt like that's that's the only way
that makes sense for me to do my part in
that space because I I'm I'm a capital
aggregator I have clients there money
people come to me to hear about things
like this
so we launched a fund of funds got it
and on the fun to fun side what are the
types of funds that you found most
interesting is it people who are picking
individual liquid tokens is it some
other strategies yeah so a couple of
really passion point big passion points
for me on this and I hope I remember
them all but like number one we are
structured mostly as a liquid product my
Redemption terms kind of forced me to
mostly stay away from VC kinds of deals
now that said even our even our liquid
guys can't help themselves when they
come across really enticing VC deals and
we've got side pockets for all of those
so I I would even say maybe I'd have to
look again twenty to thirty percent of
the fund ends up going through a VC law
you know side pocket kind of a deal
for those I don't know we talked about
in terms of redemptions if your
investment
and you say have my money back there's
usually pre-agreed to terms so it maybe
you can redeem every 30 days but I'm
gonna leave your capital locked up for a
year start or something right and the
problem is if you go and take off the
capital and the fund you invested in
illiquid deals that are gonna take three
four or five years to materialize if
everyone comes and says hey give back my
money but you the capital is in the
illiquid investments you can't actually
give them back the money so there's a
mismatch between the liquidity profiles
but by having a liquid portfolio or
exposure of liquid assets it's much
easier to get liquidity which means that
then you can serve back those
redemptions when necessary right so we
purposefully went liquid partly because
we feel like the the gap between VC and
liquidity and crypto is a really
compressed time frame compared to
traditional VC to begin with so the
alpha that you earn from traditional VC
lockups
isn't really there in crypto we think
that liquidity comes early enough that
you still capture the majority of the
beta trade in the liquid markets to
begin with does that die say that right
so make sense yeah absolutely so so that
you know that's our bent is to be liquid
number two we are we want to be with the
smartest herd in the room so I fin you
know we were talking about this a little
bit for crypto in a sense I feel like
has a bit of an insecurity complex and
wants to grow itself up and wants to be
considered institutional and so there's
a lot of work done to pigeonhole market
neutral guys versus you know coin
pickers versus absolutely return there's
just that we're trying to do what
happens in normal hedge fund investing
in crypto to make it appear like it's
becoming more grown-up and I think
that's a mistake
I don't you know I think this is a you
know this is venture capital meets
liquidity it's it's capture the beta
it's stay with the smartest guys in the
room and you better let those smart guys
adjust as the market shifts I don't want
I don't want the exposure in 17 to look
like the exposure in 18 or 19 from that
guy if he's seeing things differently
so I don't want a pigeonhole people I
just want wide mandates with the
smartest guys in the room and I want a
very small concentrated number most
traditional fund of funds 2025 funds you
know we're we're in five currently
anywhere from three to seven but beyond
that utilitarian value of that extra
manager from a statistical analysis
standpoint it's useless yeah well and
also in crypto there's not that many
funds in terms of like the denominator
and so therefore if you just say hey
some are really good some are okay and
some are bad right the number of in the
really good category it's just gonna be
much smaller very well we're very small
we think there's maybe eight or nine
like world-class funds in the game and
we're in half of them and the other half
we've chose not to be because if they're
redundant can I get you to name one
they're on my website so you can even
have all of them so it's it's metastable
multi coin haze or digital global and
block tower all horrible people yeah I
know all of them and they're just the
worst every I know some of you are
listening just you guys are so bad that
I want to be your friend now they're all
great and and I think if you look at all
of them they all have nuances to the
strategy but they all have a general
thread between what they're looking to
invest in the structure of the stage
exception is it makes a lot of sense
yeah how do you talk to your clients
about it very big picture long-term I
mean literally every time it's like look
this is the riskiest thing in your
portfolio right I mean first of all we
launched the fun January 18 so it's down
right there they've lost money so we
slowly add more capital but basically
we're like look this is this is
high-risk it can go to zero but this is
you know world-changing technology that
if if we're even half right you'll be
glad you owned this in ten years what's
the general sentiment when they're
sitting there there
about two years into the trade right
depending on when they came in they're
down but there's not the like mass
hysteria probably of like late 2018
you know December when it was down
around $3,000 Bitcoin price etc like
what's the general sentiment when you
talk to the clients you have today yeah
it's interesting because I think that
question is it's never really asked it's
it's never really confronted with my
clients because my clients you know in
an hour and a half dinner meeting will
spend five minutes on crypto five
minutes on the RV park which is going
really well five minutes on the biotech
strategy which we're not going to cover
off the ball as long as I've got a
narrative of reasonable reasonably
differentiated ideas some of what you're
working some of which are not but all
sort of heading into the direction that
I promised them we try to go I'd really
have I have zero and that's because of
the sizing the portfolio totally yeah
we're not it was 50% of the portfolio
there were a lot of questions right if
it's 1% then obviously right whole
different conversation completely yeah
and let's take on a spectrum of your
clients right so the most sophisticated
when it comes to crypto and at least
sophisticated what are the main
differences there is it just time spent
educating it is their demographic
difference so younger clients are more
inclined to be interested in older
clients all right what do you see
between the the big differences between
those sophistication levels oh that's
interesting I it's it's really just it's
really I don't think it's an age thing
most of my clients probably do tend to
be older just because most to get money
you gotta really takes time to get money
right so I can't I can't I say that's a
lesson for all the 20 year olds out
there right who are all like I want a
hundred million dollars if I look very
very few 20 year olds in the world ever
had a hundred million dollars let alone
are gonna have it in the future so I
don't think there's a correlation on the
age issue or at least in my limited data
set I don't think there is but I think
it's a personality issue it's it's
really a you know some people just don't
care and for whatever reason they got
money and they need somebody to manage
it and they just they just don't care
they don't care
other people get fascinated by
technology they get there there's an
element of curiosity that that they they
don't need they're not challenging me to
know they just they like to they'd like
to learn new things and yeah neither one
of those is right or wrong
yeah the clients who didn't have
financial exposure they get financial
exposure whether they do it or with you
guys and then you see them lean in to
kind of paying attention more and
learning because one of my theories here
is like this whole get off zero idea
right it's a look I don't care if you
got a penny or you got you know a lot of
money in exposed to any asset right it
had to be current notice anything you
start paying attention a little bit more
than for sure right and and I think that
most of the wealth managers that I've
talked to said sure they're like look
it's probably been the best thing we can
do to get these people to pay attention
is half-a-percent I totally agree I
completely agree
it just and that's not just a crypto
idea that's every every major we are for
full risk on like embracing risk capital
we are bullish for ten years on three
things biotech crypto and workforce
housing if if we can go around the
country building more RV parks if we can
press in a crypto and biotech we think
those are and so just getting a little
piece of capital in the portfolio
start small put it in the portfolio it's
a talking point when we get together
every quarter that's a hundred percent
agree with your license I am why biotech
oh man this is my latest super exciting
idea that I just can hardly contain
myself about it's very much in some ways
like crypto okay the old school I hang
with me as I explain this the old school
biotech IPO was an exit right you got
you got a you got an idea you got an
idea and a university they do a lab rat
model it goes well they raise a seed
round you know they they get the phase
one safety trials they go well phase two
you go through this process your phase
three the data is not in yet but it
looks promising and you're at the end of
the deal and it's in the privates it's
in the venture capital world and they go
IPO and it
a binary outcome it's either phase three
works the FDA says yes you turn the
revenue stream on and you make a ton of
money or something happens it doesn't
work and it goes to zero and you've
wasted all that private money that's the
old school biotech IPO not today okay
what's the difference today biotechs
going public preclinical trials why
because they can because there's the
ability in the markets that's so so
you're getting tickers trading on Wall
Street that are a lab rat model and an
idea they the FDA has not allowed them
to go into clinical trials even for a
safety trial yet now you might think
well that's crazy that's horrible risky
actually it's the opposite why because
there's a there's a lot of companies
that go from lab rat model to phase one
there's a lot of companies that go from
phase one and Phase two there's fewer
but many that go from phase 2 to phase 3
very few companies commercialize right
so if you're in a bid ask spread public
market liquid world and you come to
market and say guess what FDA said yes
we're going into the clinic for phase 1
guess what we came out of clinic we
didn't kill anybody hurt anybody we're
gonna be out loud to dose this an actual
efficacious manner to see if our regimen
our therapeutic regimen works you know
and there's multiple value creation
points along that journey where you can
win even if it fails that were before
relegated to a private world they're now
being discovered in public markets and
so is the argument that you're now
sharing the upside from the private
market into the public market so more
people can participate it is that but
it's even more about the fact that
that's that's the backdrop in the
context of how it's happening but Wall
Street doesn't know how to do well deal
with that Wall Street analysts are not
venture capital scientists and you
cannot understand the the integral sink
recedes of these of these deals without
having venture capital science so what
the AHA moment is and venture capital
scientists don't want to be in an
analyst desk
making a Wall Street panelist Ernie
right they want to be going in creating
companies so there's this natural
bifurcation of those two worlds well
that if you find a bridge if you find
access to the solid VC Science who can
look at those public tickers and say
yeah this is massively undervalued I
mean they're they've been in the clinic
now for four months they're they're due
to report phase one in three months and
if they haven't reported any they're
bound to there they're required to
report negative adverse events if they
happen they haven't reported any the
chances that the phase one turns out
thumbs up get better every day there
isn't an adverse things like that get
get don't get well understood and and so
the the bottom line is we just figured
this out over the last six six to eight
months and and I launched a liquid
biotech strategy tapping into this vici
research on October 4th and it's it's
it's just stupid money yeah it's really
good yeah the part to me that's really
interesting is you're seeing it by our
survey you just described crypto a lot
better access to to capital for
innovators and I think that this trend
across the board is going to continue as
just there's this pent up demand in
people want access to what used to be
private investments that at some point
kind of the dam breaks right it's the
only place biotech is the only place
where I'm not an alpha hater I'm I'm I'm
I actually think there's a right now
there's an arbitrage there's an a
reproducible model where alpha actually
matters there's a corner of the liquid
stock market in biotech in these really
small cap biotechs where it's completely
unorganized the market is every is
anything but efficient and and real
understanding of this venture capital
science involved gives you a massive
massive alpha trade access to
information yeah alright before we wrap
up what what do you think your clients
are
kind of headed to over the next two
years when it comes to crypto is it more
of the same do you think that more of
them lean in there are there things that
happen the crypto industry that you
think you know touch other parts that
are portfolio like how do you think
about I got a set of clients here's the
profile that they are there's this thing
crypto like how do those two things
interact moving forward yeah so you're
you're asking like do I anticipate
scaling my allocation higher would you
say is that so you could scale it higher
you could scale it lower
there could be the introduction of hey
we want to start taking parts of their
cash position and holding in stable
coins there could be tokenization of
real estate or stocks I mean so how much
just all you have in here so I don't
think about I got just so in the
two-year time frame I would say probably
will stay put I you know I really am
pitching this as a ten-year idea I don't
know I mean it could be into you two
years from now it could be that
everybody in the world understands that
crypto is is the new thing and it's
already 10 X I I don't I don't know that
I see no I'm not actually counting on
that I think there's going to be an
inflection point moment at some point in
the next five or ten years I just don't
know when in it and I would I wouldn't
want to say that I think it's gonna be
inside two years so with that risk
reward profile we we have the bet where
we want it we you know where to - as I
gained new clients organically you know
we'll add capital to the funds through
new relationships but the allocation you
know two to five percent model is really
where it nice week now if we're lucky
and it does go 20x in two years totally
every game and I don't even know what we
would do at that point whether because
because they're the trade could get
better from there so one of my questions
as always let's say you have two percent
right oh you're fine at two percent and
you see a 10x so now 20% of client
assets do you rebalance or you keep it
yeah I'm not sure I you know it's
probably dresser right is you need more
data to understand where you are in the
market etc right but it
it's very interesting because we have
the asymmetric assets you could go from
it was 2 percent now it's 10 20 percent
so yes so like number one I will not I'm
not ever gonna be the that the the
actual capital manager it will be
through my managers I don't want to have
to make a choice on a coin I don't have
the skill stress so what this is always
going to be a manage the smartest
manager kind of mentality but if if we
get you know a 10x run up from here and
it looks like 17 where there's no killer
app there it's speculation I hope that
we can have the wisdom to think about
how to to protect that if it's the
opposite and fidelity and Schwab and all
of these gargantuan monolithic financial
beasts that run our world today adapt it
and adopt it it literally there are many
killer apps in the industry is it's not
a speculative bubble it's actually an e
bit Dom measured bubble if you will I
never heard that I like that evil you
know but this is different conversation
right totally kind of what you do there
yeah absolutely
are there any companies in crypto that
really stand out you name some of the
funds that you like but any companies
that you just think that really job I
don't I probably don't have much on that
I mean I'll tell you that we have an
allocation to Nvidia is this for the
crypto exposure through like the GPUs or
just computation in general both both
yeah we think that and it's a small
allocation not in the fund of course
just in the portfolio we think we think
that space has multiple ways to win over
long obviously you're embracing you know
risk on that trade as well but beyond
that I'm I am not I'm generally not a
stock picker I'm not a technical yeah it
was it's an interesting way to think
about the crypto industry right in the
sense of taking a look at okay there's
public stocks are available yeah what
are the ones that have exposure most of
the quote-unquote blockchain public
stocks actually or that's not their DNA
right they kind of write backed into it
they changed
all kind of crazy stuff but somebody
like an Nvidia that is supplying you
know the picks and choice gels right we
think it's a we think it's the classic
picks and shovels idea
yeah it's but I'm not recommending the
stock I haven't even looked I don't even
know where it's trading today so what is
da most importantly see I did my
research and I knew you were gonna ask
you I've got these notes like let's see
your so you at least you came in here
without paper I'm not gonna call the
person I walked in here one time with
six pages of notes and I made them throw
them in the trash do not look at no you
know I love to read I didn't used to but
I listen no I'm an auto audible guy cuz
I can go you know and I like to work out
so like it kills two birds I can go one
and a half speed cruncher a lot of
material and can you run and listen to
the audio oh yeah can you lift you're
like I am I use anything that wasn't a
music anymore at the gym I don't either
I used that used to be all but it really
doesn't do me much good I mean there
anyways what do you do at the gym like
you know for workout okay oh yeah I'm
like I'm uh every other day just back
try by shoulder core so it's a full body
except my body and then on the opposite
days in the summer it's four mile run in
the winter it's a 30 minute 10-mile bike
that's like a real workout you know it
gets me sweating yeah what take like an
hour yeah yeah it's uh um I'm just
asking people what they do for workouts
because some people come in here and I'm
a person so they work that out you
actually look like you work out almost I
call [ __ ] insanity it's a sanity
check for me I can't go seven days a
week where you do six
no I so I'm getting older I'm 48 and and
every week and a half I have to take an
extra like an extra day off yeah it's
you do anything diet-wise
yeah I'm not so I like to think about it
in terms of just a lifestyle habit okay
you know so it's really not a bench
thing it's a very low car load a no-carb
one and a half meal a day like
high-protein I had chicken salad before
I showed up here
okay that's all I've had to eat just a
little bit chicken salad today and I'll
have a reasonable dinner but low to no
carb so high protein high plant you know
a simple carp no breads and sugars but
complex carbs you know vegetables tons
of those got it so just really stay away
from obscene sugars and yeah and the
bread if you can yeah it's it's
interesting because I was recently
looking at if you take two diets that
are the opposite of the spectrum so you
take the like vegetarian vegan you know
whatever variation you want and then you
take like the keto right both of them
are optimizing for quote-unquote health
but if you actually read into what type
of health they're optimizing for one is
optimizing for what I would consider
more short to medium term health and the
other one of the you know proposed
benefits of the vegetarian diet is
longevity Yeah right and so it really
becomes this thing of there's no silver
bolt right you know that there's
different dyes for different people but
also matters you what size you're
dealing and try to build mass yes we you
gotta start listening your body older I
get the more I listen to my body I
didn't used to I used to just blood in
my body with workouts and I can't do
that as much anymore but it's it it's
kind of a interesting fun little hobby
to tweak it as you get older but yeah
but on your book deal I actually have
some thought about this because I knew
that was one of the questions you like
to ask you know if you come up with a
bad a bad suggestion you thought about
it I mean so so I read books really for
mostly like three different purposes
okay right so I don't read to get
smarter I mean I do other things to get
smarter all right I don't well I don't
really think that I'm a skeptic I'm very
my natural come from is to be a linear
thinker
okay I'm pretty I feel like I'm pretty
decent at that what I need to do is I
need to be I need to be challenged at
learning how to dream better okay I need
to be able to you know I need to have an
imagination I did a very poor job of
managing money for clients early in my
career because I was I was
world's consummate skeptic I could pick
apart any deal and tell you 100 reasons
why it was the worst thing in the world
that doesn't really help people right so
I had to learn how to get imagination so
I read to be inspired I read to use more
nonfiction on the scene totally
nonfiction but you know the truth is
stranger than fiction
I love the the biographies that are just
crazy stories and could could have to do
with anything but if it's a true story
and it's inspiring I like it you know
what are the best ones oh there's a ton
of them I you know you give me one I'll
give you one lets you runs out right out
did you to the Immortal Life of
Henrietta Lacks okay I heard that I have
not haven't read it but I'll put that on
the list so she is a girl who lived in
the 30s or 40s without giving a punch
line there are more living cells of her
body alive today than there were when
she was alive and he lacks is the
backbone of every scientific experiment
that's done he was and it it's just it's
a crazy story Henry and the Immortal
Life of Henrietta Lacks Henrietta okay
Sam Zell am I being too subtle okay he
basically he was all in real estate
yong-dae said probably over indexed I
should diversify someone take 50% no put
it in taking companies public and then
all sudden he saw a REIT for the first
time I said wait a minute I am an expert
in real estate I'm an expert in taking
companies public I should do that and
next thing you know you built the forty
billion dollar board just read in the
world and sold it the black stuff who
I'm gonna cheat and say two books Steve
Schwarzman just wrote a book and in his
book it's called what it takes
he describes when he starts what became
Blackstone they ran an ad in The Wall
Street Journal and thought you were
going to call nobody calls of the say
congratulations on your new company they
want to give me some business I will
consider your frozen you know later gets
a knock at the door and there's a guy
the motorcycle helmet and he thought it
was the food delivery though this guy
was and guy says uh you know here's talk
to Steve Schwarzman cuz that's me who
are you
he goes uh my sister so I should come
see you and literally had his bike
chained up outside the only store he
goes and guy in the motorcycle helmet
walks in and there's no furniture so
they're supposed to be sitting on the
ground and they just talked for a couple
hours and that's how Steve Schwarzman
met Sam's though oh that is fascinating
what's the name of that book what it
takes is D Schwartzman yeah I need to
read those thirty years later Blackstone
bought Sam's ELLs Wow reap and so it's
just it's interesting how the world
turns alright what's your next one read
notice that's oh man I love that love
that book I it's probably it's up
there's my top three most recommended
books over the last couple years to
people because it is it's unbelievable
it's totally unbelievable dude this like
you I have seen Putin on TV mentioned
this guy's name and I'm like that's
that's know so those they don't know
there's a book called read notice it's
about a guy Bill Browder who was
American investor who went to Russia did
a bunch of investing he's turned sour
and you've ever heard of the Magnitsky
act here in the u.s. that sanction a
bunch of Russians yeah
he's basically the reason for it and so
it's such a crazy story that actually
saw on Twitter this is maybe a couple
months ago whenever it was he was in
Spain and he got picked up by the
Spanish authorities under the red notice
right some red notice is basically like
a FB i--'s I did not know this and he's
only for a couple hours and then he got
released but they were kind of just you
know making sure whatever and it was a
very stark reminder of like the books
interesting right the bid is education
you know it's entertaining and all stuff
- real life for this guy yeah that's
crazy just finished Tarot west overs
book educated oh I see okay you're the
second person to mentioned is it good
I actually thought it was really good
really good
highly unusual did you read oh man I'm
gonna forget Ashley advances book
actually yeah Ashley Vance the book
about like people in West Virginia
mm-hmm tell me the other one I'm the fun
and you know so completely different not
not quite as inspiring but the closest
that I get to trying to read for being
smart I did read house of Morgan I read
there's a new Churchill biography how
these are both massive 50-hour books
yeah but but I like you know historical
like these are things where you
basically deal with the financial system
in this country for 150 years and you
see generation after generation of
people dealing with stuff that we're
probably going to deal with again at
some point and it's just an interesting
context I think it's it's helpful just
to have some background in context yeah
yeah books called hillbilly le oh I did
read that one yeah yeah alright so I got
one last suggestion and we'll talk about
aliens sure we on this is not a book
it's documentary have you seen the men
who built America no man if you liked
how some organ and stuff you gotta go
watch this so it it was on television
when it first came out you can now
either buy it or you can even doesn't
like you to be kind of patched together
the different sections it is an eight
part series from the History Channel and
it starts with I think the first one
starts with is Carnegie then it has
rockefeller JP Morgan and it's got like
two or three others I forget Edison's in
there
Tesla etc and it basically goes through
the story of essentially the Industrial
Revolution and what each one of those
players was doing and kind of how
America got built and you find that like
I'll give you one detail that I didn't
know
now I haven't washed it just here to my
brain so John Rockefeller was looking
for oil very quickly realized rather
than me be the guy you know the idiot
poked in the ground for the oil why
don't I become the refiner because then
I can make sure I have a more
sustainable business and then he struck
a deal I think it was with maybe was
Vanderbilt I think I sure could deal
with and said hey I will give you access
to my oil so that you can put on your
rail cars and now you have a business
right because you're gonna have all of
my oil and at some point along the way
they basically start to you know twist
his arm and say hey well you need our
rails to get your oil anywhere and so
they say you're gonna pay us more and at
some point there's basically a lockout
when I say you can't use our rails ain't
one lets you you know do what we want
you to do and so he is a very creative
and an ambitious person says well what
if I just created pipes and then he
created the ones seriously and so the
way that it was out of necessity right
the innovation came from this s amount
of he no longer could put his oil in
barrels on rail cars and so instead what
he did was he said well I'll just build
oil pipes and I will literally pump it
or take from the refineries push it
through these pipes and I'll get it to
where it needs to go and now you know
basically you lost my business and you
can't stop me that's really fascinating
and so there's example after example you
know as you start to realize this
there's a reason why you know JP Morgan
is a big name right it was a big name
they did a lot of stuff that no that's
the that's the antithesis of that
skepticism I was telling you about
trying to grow out of yeah personally so
the men who built America aren't aliens
real or not this one is another one that
I I knew you you might ask I have kind
of a maybe a backward answer for okay I
actually think the entire question is a
back door question to your your view the
world of course I've said it many times
the reason why I ask the question is it
tells you how people think yeah meaning
is there intelligent design or not okay
origins of the universe type of deal
because if if you
your answers are gonna naturally
bifurcate coming down or you would think
your answers would naturally bifurcate
coming down that so i you know i'm i'm
in the intelligent design camp i'm in
the you know traditional judeo-christian
view of the world so that would
naturally probably put me in the
campus's know they can't exist but i am
actually not there i would say you know
in the national in the natural
judeo-christian view of the world the
pinnacle of creation is ma'am which
would mean that to have other life forms
evolved ahead of us wouldn't wouldn't
really necessarily coexist and I would
actually subscribe to that but you me
this is the worlds the universe is a big
place so there's no reason why God could
not have superintended an evolutionary
process 2 : 8 with man and have aliens
on 5 million planets in the universe
I got a stat for you for the next time
you're at the trivia tonight at the
local bar how many planets are there out
there for every grain of sand on earth
Wow
woody how many planets per grain of sand
in the universe clearly it's more than a
one-to-one ratio I have no idea ten
thousand ten thousand one ten thousand
planets for every grain of sand on earth
yeah that's see so yes that scares the
[ __ ] out of it is it's a it's a fairly
myopic view first of all it's fairly
mild it's it's actually normal for
judeo-christian worldview people to be
myopic in their thinking but you know
the facts are it's fairly myopic to
think that that we're we're it yeah so
that's that comes from there's a new
Netflix explained series on there use
the word aliens because that's too taboo
so they use like artificial and you know
extraterrestrial life or whatever
terminology they use but that that
wasn't there then the other things I
read right now there are two galaxies
that are colliding and we are going to
hit them in like two or four billion
years no I'm out man I got my computer I
gotta go do something over yeah it's
interesting stuff kid cuz I also saw
there's meteors right now coming towards
Earth and this is supposed to be you
know one of these that like hey we
should be paying attention to you know
whatever and it's like a nice a look
whether they're right or not we have no
way to check we don't we'll see that's
that's my you know either way if you're
if you're atheist you're agnostic you're
Christian your Hindu your Buddhist it
ultimately comes down to not science
this is nobody's there to observe how
this stuff happened so it you you're a
man of faith whether you're a man of
faith believing in Jesus or in the fact
that there is no God one or the other
either way it's a great way to look at
the world what uh what one question you
have for me to finish this up what is
the most exciting interesting non crypto
investment that you are stoked about
like right now that you cannot that
we've done know that you're into that
you're like right now I'm not gonna
cover off the ball this is like this is
the cooling I maybe there's nothing I
don't I don't want to say the name of
the companies I don't know what they're
comfortable with me saying or not but
they're well there's a couple of waste
answers so first somebody said to me I
was the sky Bruce event who came he's an
ancient alien researchers love you Bruce
but come only percent of the way there
with you
and he said look every human has two
questions the first is are we alone
right meaning is there extraterrestrial
life and two is what happens when we die
right every humid at some point the life
will think of those two things I believe
that here on earth answering one of
those two questions would be one of the
greatest you know achievements in life
sure maybe now I don't think
that somebody's gonna be said what
happens after we die but it just
conceptually would be very difficult to
do along those lines though we invested
in a business that scientifically has
figured out how to freeze your brain
what I mean by that is it essentially in
a very over-generalized non scientific
way
delivers cryogenic freezing technology
to your brain at the point of death
so as you're dying puts it pushes this
in there through this oxygenating
process freezes your brain with a
hundred percent structural integrity by
doing that what the belief is is that
they can actually freeze your synapse
connections what exists in those
electrical connections experiences
knowledge right emotions all this kind
of stuff so if I can basically salvage
and preserve emotions the consciousness
all kind of stuff can I then take it and
upload it to a computer
and so therefore imagine if we had
Thomas Edison's brain and we can feed it
new problems right so not so much in the
or there's some people who say oh this
technology would be great because when I
come back right so that kind of right
you know more sci-fi stuff right there's
some people would just say hey look by
being able to do this we can do research
right so there's kind of you know
directly applicable science or this kind
of middle ground of okay I'm not there
yet I'm like humans come back right and
I'm not there I'm like I can
cryogenically freeze you and then revive
you later but I do see this world where
I could essentially take what's in your
head put it into a computer and then I
can't necessarily evolve it from there
but I can feed new problems to it and
use the frameworks mindset you know
always kinda stuff that you have to me I
don't know if that's the right answer
but this combination of taking human
brain and intelligence and combining it
with computational power I think a lot
of people are thinking about it how do I
take the computer and put it into the
brain Yeah right
and Olga minute that way and you're
doing the opposite this companies doing
it opposite but just like either
direction I think is super interesting
because you could say how cool would it
be if I don't have you know I had a look
up
hillbilly led the book right yeah well
if I had a chip in my brain I could just
immediately tell you big inflection
point in human history well the night
that's cool the common thread is you
know the human genome project I think is
nearly 20 years old now and the the
order of magnitude that mapping has done
in clinical trials is it's breathtaking
over the last 20 years but it's an
asymptotic curve into the future the
next 20 years are gonna be by an order
of magnitude larger than the last in
terms of the scientific advances that we
can do in the human body based on our
understanding of the human genome in our
ability to construct trials accordingly
it's it's it's a it's one of the reasons
why we're massively bullish biotech in
general yeah it's we know more about the
surface of Mars I think then we know
about our oceans right no their same
thing could be said about the human body
we we know a lot you don't know nearly
as much as we probably should so you
know a lot of work to cut out all right
listen there's one of the longer ones
I've done in a while so I appreciate it
this is a longer we go the weirder again
so if you're still listening here you're
a trooper actually if you're still
listening the first three people to
tweet at me with the words aliens are at
the end of the podcast I'll send you
something specialist to see who made it
all the way here thank you so much for
coming to do this and we're gonna have
to do this again welcome do it in
Chicago would be fun
let me bless I appreciate it thanks for
having me has a lot of fun for sure